This tiny robot may look unassuming,
but even at a mere 100 grams—
about as heavy as a bar of soap—
the “FlyCroTug” can pull up to 40 times its own weight..
To create the mighty FlyCroTug -- named for its
flying, micro, tugging features --
researchers took a cue from wasps.
Typically, these insects use their stinger to subdue prey
before transporting it back to their nest.
If the prey is too heavy to fly with,
some wasps plant their feet on the ground
and pull their prey home.
Similarly, when a payload is too heavy for flight --
anything bigger than the robot itself --
the FlyCroTug stays on terra firma,
whereit uses adhesives and tiny metal hooks called
microspines to stick to a surface,
and a powerful tether to tug on an object.
Researchers demonstrated the FlyCroTug’s capabilities
by anchoring it atop a partially collapsed building
and having it haul up a bulky set of sensors
to inspect small openings in the rubble.
FlyCroTugs can also work together to open doors
one pulls the handle downwards
while sticking to the door itself,
and another pulls the door open
while anchored to the ground.
The FlyCroTug still has room for improvement -
it’s 5 minute flight time limits the robots
to only short-range operations
and more difficult, multi-step tasks
require more than one FlyCroTug.
Still, FlyCroTug’s unprecedented strength
gives it an advantage over other miniature drones
which—due to their size—can typically
only survey their environment
instead of actually interacting with it.
That could make this new class of robots
useful in everything from
planting sensors in hard-to-reach spots
to removing debris in disaster zones.